j'entends bien que emmanuel macron par
exemple aujourd'hui parce que il y à un
concours de circonstances d'abord c'est
une personnalité de qualité ça a été un
très bon ministre
deuxièmement il semble vouloir
s'abstraire des comment tirer jeter
pesanteurs qui est de gauche qui est de
droite il semble aussi être relativement
peu précis encore sur les engagements
qui sont les siens et ceci correspond à
rien que ça il dresse le diagnostic et
enfin vous l'avez entendue et écoutée
chez moi ça m'intéresse de toute façon
je suis intéressé par par part justement
ce travail intellectuel j'espère qu'il
va être produit j'espère qu'il sera de
qualité et j'espère qu'il servira de
notre pays et la gauche
d'une façon générale mais vous parlez
comme de lui en disant c'est un concours
de circonstances qui se retrouve le
mieux placé il est aujourd'hui en je
pense si vous voulez je ne pense pas que
je ne le fais pas de procès d'intention
je constate que sur ce je constate qu'il
n'a pas produit pour l'instant les
éléments politiques qu'ils fassent qu'à
mon avis la démarche qui est la sienne
soit crédible et durable
voilà maintenant je peux rouge attend
d'être comme on démontre le contraire
idéologiquement vous êtes quand même
assez proche de lui vous pourriez le
soutenir à l'avenir mais moi j'ai
toujours soutenu j'étais un réformiste
je suis animateur du pôle réformiste je
l'avais invité une autre université
d'été
à pessac léognan j'ai des nuances jeu
par exemple je suis pas socialisée râle
je suis quelqu'un qui est sur une
position effectivement pro entreprises
je crois mais je pense que l'état a un
rôle je pense que le régalien comme on
dit aujourd'hui un rôle et je ne suis
pas dans cet essai des nuances mais et
des nuances que que j'apprécie et et
donc il peut être tout à fait utile il
peut être utile il peut être tout à fait
dommageable à la gauche il peut détruire
la gauche comme l'a dit manuel valls en
oui si si sa candidature s'avérait être
une candidature qui fait que la gauche
ne peut pas être la gauche deux
responsabilités
moi je pense qu'il faut la clarification
de ce point de vue je suis d'accord avec
lui faut une clarification politique